pour la créatrice c'est comme un retour
aux sources
originaire de versailles où elle a
grandi jusqu'à ses 17 ans agnès b a
ouvert le 10 mai dernier la première
enseigne de sa marque dans la ville du
roi soleil
quarante ans après l'ouverture de son
premier point de vente à paris j'ai
voulu rester un peu versailles est
justement l on est resté dans des tons
c'est gris clair que j'adore les volets
gris clair comme ça
la maison et jaune pâle alors on est
resté avec des stores jaune pad on a
voulu coller au contraire à
l'architecturé au lieu de plain pied un
truc qui aurait été différent c'est ça
que j'ai voulu faire une boutique lui
ressemble avec 90 mètres carrés de
surface qui s'étale sur trois pièces et
un espace pour les hommes qui seront
l'objet de sa première collection la
nouvelle collection c'est l'homme que je
présente le 24 juin
voilà alors c'est l'homme était prochain
j'ai déjà fait l'hiver puis j'ai
présenté mois de janvier après il ya eu
marre sa femme juin l'homme et octobre
la femme jusqu'au
un emploi du temps surchargé pour la
créatrice qui enchaîne collections et
des filets dont le travail a été
récompensé la veille par le président de
la république
c'était commandeur région donnée sur le
salat rouge avec la légion d'honneur
c'était émouvant de morand pour moi de
remercier un faible
un enthousiasme et une énergie que la
créatrice a su mettre à profit dans son
travail
une nouvelle boutique dans une ville
qu'elle dit n'avoir jamais quitté qui
s'ajoutent 250 enseignes qui s'exporte
même à l'international